- You won't vote.
You're not gonna vote.
- Young voters often being considered
politically uninterested.
- Young voters here could
make a big difference.
- You're not gonna vote.
Hey, you hear me?
Why do I know that?
Because, I'm just using
basic statistics here.
YouTube tells me that 71% of my audience,
all of you watching,
are between the ages of
18 and 34 years old, okay?
That's me too, I'm 32
years old, so whatever.
I'm in this demographic.
We could also be represented on a graph
that shows how many of
us shows up to the polls
every election.
Back in the 80's that
number was around 50%, half.
And then by the 90's it
dipped down really low,
to like 40%.
And then it went up a little,
and then in 2016,
the last general election, it was 46%.
Meanwhile, the older
folks are way up here,
in like the 60's and 70's.
People over 65 have almost
50% more representation
in our democracy, because
simply, they show up to polls
and they vote.
Whereas, a lot of us stay home.
But here's what blows my mind about this,
as I think about it this year,
I was this guy.
Like, I was this guy.
I was the person who didn't vote.
Didn't really think about this as some
super important thing.
Let's just like rewind
at me being this guy, in 2012.
Of course, I was on YouTube
watching all the celebrities telling me
that it's my civic duty
to go out and vote.
- It's only one wrong vote,
and that is no vote.
- And they would use
this weird phrase like,
get out and vote.
It was like, "Get out, and vote".
- So, on November 4th, get out and vote.
- Why are we saying get out all the time?
So weird, like it's, what a weird phrase.
We don't use that for anything else.
I would hear these celebrities
and I would kind of
roll my eyes.
Like yeah, I get it, we're in a democracy,
this is important, but,
it's not that important.
And you know what added to all of this
for me in 2012?
Is that these ads, these celebrities,
they made it sound so easy.
Just like, "Take a couple
minutes and go vote".
Like, it's actually not that easy.
Voting in America requires
a bit of research,
and a bit of effort.
Not a ton,
but more than what a lot of
people make it sound like.
And this is all made
muddier by the fact that
every state has specific rules.
I was moving around a lot at this time.
I was in Oregon, and then I was in Utah,
and then I was in Virginia.
And every one of these states
has slightly different rules
on how to register, when to register,
how to actually vote.
Which is why there's a YouTube channel
literally dedicated to
how to vote in every state.
It requires a tutorial.
So yeah, voting requires a little bit of
research and effort, and we
should be upfront about that.
Look at this ranking of 20 democracies
ranked by how much young
people show up to vote.
Of course, up here we have
the Scandinavian countries,
who has a huge majority of
people under 30 who vote.
Cool, we get it, Scandinavia,
you've figured out how to
run countries and societies
in a very democratic and
functional way, okay?
Let's just, why don't you
keep bragging about it?
Scroll down a little bit, a lot,
and you get to the United States,
way down here.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, what,
what's going on here?
Hold on.
What is going on?
Switzerland is even lower, 33%.
Switzerland, my Switzerland?
Wait, but I thought Switzerland was like
the perfect country.
There's gotta be a good reason for this.
I mean, Switzerland does
have political parties
that share power,
and so elections aren't
really that important,
and they have all these referenda, and so.
- [Wife] Oh my gosh, just
admit that it's not perfect.
- I'm just not willing to do that.
- [Wife] Okay.
- Ahem, you can go back to your computer.
I need to take a break,
and tell you about today's sponsor,
for a minute,
to sort of refresh.
Today's sponsor is SimpliSafe,
which is kind of a cool thing.
This box arrived at my house,
I opened it up,
and it was a bunch of security stuff.
All of these things that um,
I've never really had before.
I guess I've always associated
security system companies,
with being these sort of sleazy salesmen
that show up to your house,
and make you sign all these contracts,
and before you know it,
you're like in a five year commitment.
This was like the
literal opposite of that.
It was a box that showed up to my house,
there was no drama,
there was no commitment,
there was no signing.
I have a studio that has
a bunch of gear in it,
and I've always sort of
in the back of my head
wondered like, should I
have a security system?
And I've thought yes,
but the problem is it's always been
sort of intimidating for me
to think about how to even do that.
SimpliSafe is very easy solution
for getting security into your home
in a very non-threatening way.
What I like about this,
is that it's incredibly accessible.
It takes less than an hour to set up.
You can put sensors on whatever
doors or windows you want,
or think are necessary.
You can put up their HD
cameras wherever you want,
the motion sensors.
You can just customize it.
You don't need some salesman or technician
to come out, and like,
soup up your house,
you can just do it yourself in an hour,
with these really easy to use tools.
That's a big selling point for me.
No commitments, or contracts, or anything.
It's just really nice to use technology,
that helps secure your house 24/7.
Once it's set up,
it has an automated feature
that calls the police
if there's any breaches
in your security system.
These products have won awards,
and I'm not surprised why,
they're just really useful
so, there's a link in my description
that when you click,
it helps support this channel,
but it also helps you learn
more about SimpliSafe,
and how you can get a
security setup for yourself.
So, go click that link,
and go check it out.
Thank you, SimpliSafe.
Okay, let's get back to voting.
I'm still not very happy
about the Switzerland flex
over there from my wife.
- [Wife] Just admit that it's not perfect.
- Okay, so back to voting.
Less than half of people
under 30 don't vote.
And what does this actually
mean for our society?
Well, it means that older people
have way more representation
to elect other older people,
who have different
perspectives and priorities
than younger people do.
Tax cuts for rich people,
who tend to be older people, check.
They usually don't want
things to change very much,
because they've sorta
been doing it the same way
for so many years, check.
The changing climate,
yeah, they certainly care
about climate change,
but like, they're not
gonna be on the Earth
for that much longer.
So, it's like they don't actually care,
they don't have skin in the game
with the climate change thing.
This is why one election expert said that,
if younger people showed up to the polls
in the same proportions as older people,
it would fundamentally
transform American politics.
But wait, let's go back to 2012 Johnny,
and go through another
thing that was in his head.
Because, one of the big things,
is I was living in Utah at the time.
Which is a deeply red state
that was definitely
gonna go for Mitt Romney,
and I was an Obama person.
And so, I was thinking,
my vote doesn't count.
Which is actually a very
tempting line of thinking,
and probably a major reason
why a lot of people don't vote.
But now that I have studied a
lot of different governments,
and how things work in
the world, I realize that
that line of thinking is totally wrong.
First off, there are loads
of people on that ballot
that are not running for president,
that are running for state, and local,
and county positions,
that incidentally, have way more effect
on your day to day life
than the presidential election.
Sorry to break it to you,
but like, presidential
election gets all the limelight
and attention, actually probably affects
your life a lot less.
Anyway.
Plus that whole idea of,
my vote doesn't count,
is not how democracy works.
Oftentimes democracy feels like
a winner takes all situation,
where whoever wins,
wins and they do whatever
they want, because they won.
That's not totally the case.
Even if you vote for a losing candidate,
democracy is a game of
pressuring and signaling leaders.
Lemme explain what I mean.
Leaders of course, take note of protests,
and petitions, and
other forms of activism.
But the thing they really care about,
the thing that really pressures them,
is the vote.
Because that is the only
thing that can actually
lose them their jobs.
Even if your candidate loses,
let's say you are a red
person voting in a blue state,
or a blue person voting in
a red state, or whatever,
the winner of that
election will still note
the results of their opponent.
If there's a huge turnout
for your candidate,
even though they lost,
the winner of that election will notice,
and they will take note,
and they will factor
that into their behavior,
and to their decision making.
That is a fact.
That is how democracy works.
Because they need to keep an eye on it,
because they realize that
if there was a big turnout
for their opponent this time,
they need to keep an eye on that,
for the next election.
On the other hand,
if you don't vote and you stay home,
that candidate who won,
has zero pressure.
They feel zero pressure
to behave any differently,
because they won so comfortably.
Voting isn't just about
voting for the winner,
it's about signaling to everyone,
what the actual political diversity is,
in your city, or your county,
or your state or your country.
Your vote actually does matter,
even when it feels like it doesn't.
And this took me a while to like,
actually accept,
but now I see it very clearly.
Not only in our democracy,
but in democracies around the world.
Okay, I know I sound like I'm sort of
getting all lecturey here,
there are a lot of really
good, rational reasons
why young people don't vote.
Often, we have less flexible jobs,
so it isn't easy for us to
take time out to go vote,
and it can cost us a
lot of money to do that.
Often we haven't made a habit out of it.
People that are over 65 have
been doing this for a while.
They've had time to develop the habit,
and get used to the experience of voting,
and honestly, that positive association
of going to the polls, voting,
feeling good about it,
and then the next time you're like,
"Oh I wanna do that again".
Young people haven't had the
experience of doing that yet.
And listen, I don't think this
video's gonna suddenly change
this line, and just
have it start to go up,
and suddenly we have a 70%
turnout for young people,
though that would be really like psh,
change our entire country.
But I do think something is changing.
I think us young people are realizing that
a lot of real, serious threats
are being created and
exacerbated by the old folks
that have been running things
for a really long time.
And that those threats could
actually have huge affects
on our future, and our
future job prospects,
what our society looks like.
And I think we're realizing that yeah,
even though you have to
do a little research,
and that voting laws
are a little different
in every state, that
it's worth the effort.
Even if our candidate loses,
to send a signal about what we want
and what we care about in our democracy.
(upbeat music)